Okay, now we are going to cover how much content do you really need on your website and I would
say that you want to look at your competition.
So once you do the due diligence, you know what the top three websites are that are ranking
in that area.
Look at how much content they have on their pages and double that, double the competition.
So do better than everyone else that you're trying to rank for.
And then the standard, if you want to know an average, would be we usually do 2,000 words
for the homepage and then we do 1,000 words for each service pages.
So that's 3,000.
If you have a website with one homepage and three service pages, that is 5,000 words worth
of content.
And then I know that we have a contact page, but we actually do not write content for the
contact page.
And that is it.